[Applause]
[Music]
took part in one of her most unique
interviews to date to coincide with the
release of her new netflix series the
chair the canadian actress answered
questions from the young los angeles
bass punk group the linda lindes whose
new song oh is featured as the official
trailer track for sandra's new show
[Music]
[Applause]
so of course the talented all-female
band had to ask the award-winning
actress if she plays any instruments
herself growing up in a you know a
korean immigrant household
uh
myself and my siblings all played piano
but i did not want to
i hated practicing so much i would
record myself
and play the recording and my mom would
be in the kitchen just would think that
i was like practicing and i would just
play the recording the 50 year old also
revealed what she was like as a child
and why filming the chair was one of her
most enjoyable professional experiences
to date one of the ways i've been
extremely lucky is that i knew
when i was your age that all i wanted to
do was be an actor
and that's honestly all i have done
you've been in so many movies and tv
shows or some of the most fun ones the
chair was really fun
it was bananas
it was so bananas trying to shoot it was
like it was in the you know the height
of the pandemic because in some ways it
was so tough to shoot the chair
people would come out with crazy ideas
and and we would just get on an energy
flow and it it would be it would be a
lot of fun even though it was really
hard it was probably one of my most
really hard but my most fun experiences